maintenant que nous en arrivions à ce
qui fera l'essentiel de l'émission
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire notre grande
enquête
elle porte sur un thème vaste et ô
combien important le gaspillage des
mesures récentes dont vous attendu par
les séjours dernier et on parle aussi
beaucoup depuis que l'on connaît
certaines difficultés
d'approvisionnement en pétrole
particulièrement font que la lutte
contre le gaspillage est venu maintenant
au premier plan de l'actualité or cette
lutte contre le gaspillage pour des
raisons économiques rejoint porte
heureusement une certaine forme d'action
que l'on mène maintenant dans la défense
de l'environnement
quand on pense aux plastiques qui par
exemple y nom d'un certain nombre de
régions de plage ou le verra cet été et
que l'on sait que l'on pourrait recycler
c'est ce plastique et les réutiliser par
exemple on s'aperçoit qu'il y à fort à
faire et bien ce sujet la lutte contre
le gaspillage
nous avons essayé de le traiter du moins
de commencer à le traiter dans l'
enquête que vous allez voir inquiéter en
particulier mené avec monsieur claude
guillemin qui le directeur du brgm
c'est à dire le bureau de recherches
géologiques et minières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va être de plus en plus difficiles à
se procurer et l'énergie les matières
premières qui sont dans le fond deux
aspects d'une même prise des choses
deviennent rares des choses qui étaient
communes avant dont on croyait qu'on
pourrait les utiliser comme ça jusqu'à
plus soif sans qu'ils aient jamais
d'arrêt pour l'humanité eh bien on
s'aperçoit qu'en réalité elles sont plus
ou moins limitée plus ou moins difficile
de les envisager pour un avenir très
lointain
[Musique]
où
jusqu'à présent nous avons une économie
basée essentiellement sic heinz on a une
économie basée sur la consommation la
concernant la production à outrance
permettant une consommation à outrance
et permettant donc une croissance du
niveau de vie on a confondu la
croissance en quantité avec la
croissance qu'en qualité
on peut parfaitement l m vous avez votre
enfant par exemple vous êtes très
content qui grandit jusqu'à 18 19 20 ans
mais si grand qu'il ya 45 ans 72 ans ça
pose des problèmes sauf pour les cirques
donc à partir de 20 ans vous êtes bien
content et ce moment là de voir votre
enfant qui s'arrêtent de grandir au
point de vue quantité mais on espère
qu'ils continuent à grandir en qualités
pour devenir un homme respectable
steve atteint mon âge quand ils ont donc
une affaire comme la france doit
complètement modifié ses structures
industrielles ces structures de
consommation et elle devra peu à peu en
effet cesser une économie qui était basé
sur le gaspillage des matières premières
et de l'énergie pour revenir à une
économie à une économie ou à des
économies wayne économie d économie
mixte ordinaire faire comme les grands
mais regardez les morceaux de papier
embellie non pas la bouteille sans
tomber dans un excès d'ailleurs parce
qu'il faut tout de même bien se dire il
faut toujours aller s qui est
économiquement faisable et là dans ce
cas là c'est ce qu'ils consomment moins
d'énergie à conserver qu'à se procurer
des nouvelles ce qu'on peut considérer
malgré tout c'est que dans ce qui est
jeté actuellement il y a un pourcentage
qui sicile à définir mais extrêmement
important
sont recyclables on peut dire sans trop
exagérer que avec une politique bien
mise au point en quelques années nous
pourrions récupérer 80% de ce que nous
consommons et plaît pas au point de vue
énergétique malheureusement comme vous
le savez c'est ce qui est brûlé en
énergie se récupère pratiquement c'est à
dire que non seulement un pays comme le
nôtre a beaucoup de déchets ce qui il ya
encore six mois était un beau fleuron
c'est à dire que l'on mesurait le
bien-être une population nombre de
saletés qu'on pouvait jeter dans la
nature mais en plus ces déchets il n'en
fait rien une petite tartine
actuellement et récupérer ça dépend
d'ailleurs des différents déchets on
distingue des déchets des déchets
urbains comprenant tous que jette les
ménagères puisque ces petits commerçants
présents douleur ça représente combien
environ 12 millions de tonnes chaque
année 300 kg par français qui est et on
sait déjà tout de même pas mal
puis dans ses 12 millions de tonnes ya
des tas de produits intéressants à 4
millions de tonnes de papier ont
beaucoup de métal également pendant des
boîtes de conserve et également certains
métaux non ferreux et des éleveurs et le
vert puisque ça contient 80 % à peu près
du verre d'emballage à peu près en
termes de forêt 4 millions de tonnes de
papier ça veut dire quoi
vous pouvez compter à peu près
une tonne de papier un hectare et demi
de forêt 4 millions de tonnes de papier
ça fait 6 millions d'hectares de forêt
ça fait trois fois la forêt française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
peut admettre que de 30 à 40 % des
emballages ne sert strictement à rien on
pourrait parfaitement sans penser donc
c'est et des matières premières qui sont
qui sont gras chez pour rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'arrêt du gaspillage permettrait très
certainement de diminuer
considérablement la quantité de déchets
gars les emballages qui sont absolument
nécessaires
on pense par exemple à ce qu'il contient
mais l'entamé vin ou de l'eau mais qui
n'est pas obligé d'éteindre le thériault
qui lui doit jeter
il ya tout le problème qui se repose
maintenant des emballages récupérables
il faudra absolument qu'on se retranche
sur ce domaine sur la sensible sur la
consigne ou revenir un certain nombre
d'emballages consignes
[Applaudissements]
avec la consignation il ya beaucoup plus
de travail alors que le client pense à
bouteilles et s'en va que c'est terminé
ou alors qu'il faut faire le compte des
bouteilles rendu et tout ça que c'est
très long une pourquoi perdre de temps
moi je suis pas ouvert perdu est-ce que
je suis une femme dit 120 kg pas le
temps cette apathie et c'était
embarrassant aux pratiques
est-ce que c'est pas pour rien 30
centimes que convié son bar à celle d'un
panier du theil pas très propre non plus
que ce qu'on savait pas si elle est ou
non le leader évidemment maintenant
l'emballage en plastique que l'on peut
jeter alors le verre est perdue comme
cela on le jette à fond là c'est un
problème d'ordures si je peux dire c'est
plus un problème de ménagères
si l'emballage et dégradable objets
dégradables je suppose que s'il n'est
pas consigné c'est pas grave on peut
jeter n'importe où le problème n'est pas
posée ici justement c'est du plastique
ou des matières qui ne sont pas
biodégradables
le fait que qu'elle ne soit pas consigné
produits nuisance au niveau de
l'environnement
vous voyez ces bouteilles étoilé qui
sont consignés 35 francs on ne vous les
trouverez jamais dans les poubelles
tout le monde les rapporte si on venait
à l'ancien système ça nous donnerait
beaucoup de manutention au point de vue
consommateur le client paye le vert et
en plus il ya beaucoup devaient rejeter
alors qu'avant il y en avait moins il
est absolument anormal actuellement
d'avoir des emballages plastiques qui
sont jetés quand on sait que malgré tout
les réserves en carbone et aux
hydrocarbures susceptible de donner des
plastiques sont tout de même
relativement limité
[Musique]
on a bien plus d'intérêt à utiliser des
matières premières qui existe en grande
quantité dans le sous-sol dans les corps
célestes dans le sous sol de la terre
est utilisé de la silice la civis et des
milliards de milliards de milliards de
tonnes de silice qui tint phillies et de
l'aluminium c'est des milliards de
milliards de milliards de tonnes
d'aluminium
donc ça pratiquement par rapport à
l'espèce humaine c'est infini tandis
qu'on sait parfaitement que tout ce qui
est con du stic fossiles ça c'est limité
c'est limité dans le temps
alors la récupération il faudrait
demander aux ménagères de deux mètres
d'un côté des papiers de l'autre côté
des bouteilles non non non c'est pas
vrai s'est pas forcé il serait il serait
meilleur de toute façon de faire deux
grandes classes tout ce qui pourrit
facilement et puis tout ce qui est au
contraire matériaux c'est-à-dire papier
carton verre boîte concert mais sans
chercher quelque chose que d'autres trop
bien séparés
ça serait d'ailleurs même pas rentable
passé trop de temps pour faire une
séparation à la base étant donné qu'il y
a tout de même des méthodes et c'est
justement ce que nous étudions ici pour
pouvoir séparer des matériaux défini à
partir d'un mélange et les ordures c'est
un gigantesque mélange il faut en effet
séparer les déchets pour éliminer ce qui
n'est pas récupérable et garder les
matériaux qui peuvent être réintroduits
dans le cycle de production
deux expériences de ramassage sélectif
viennent d'être mises au point l'une à
la rochelle l'autre dans la ville du 1
nous pourrions récupérer environ 7000
tonnes de vieux papiers et journaux
cartons dans les ordures ménagères et
que cela représente pour une ville donc
de 250000 habitants la sauvegarde
d'environ cent vingt mille arbres
c'est à dire qu'un 100 hectares de forêt
c'était donc notre première
préoccupation
la deuxième c'est que notre pays a
besoin de pâte à papier chaque année il
est importé ce sont les chiffres de 72
que je vous donne 2 millions 300 mille
tonnes de pâte à papier pour répondre
aux besoins de l'économie nationale et
une très grande partie de ce tonnage
pourraient être récupérés dans les
ordures ménagères enfin n'avons pas été
indifférent au fait que tout ce papier
récupéré n'aura pas besoin d'être brûlé
dans l'usiné d'incinération et comme
chaque tonne d'ordures brûlé nous
revient à 30 français est autant de
gagner pour les finances communales
pour nous c'était un progrès ça nous
arrange énormément quand nous étions
débordés par les cartons et puis ma foi
sur le plan je pense nationale c'est une
bonne chose ça protégera effectivement
certainement la nature et les arbres et
on a énormément besoin de papier
actuellement
[Applaudissements]
dans la nature ya pratiquement rien qui
s'échappe de la terre on est un globe
sur ce globe il ya des métaux il ya de
l'eau il ya des matières biologiques
tout cela se transforme continuellement
en cours des âges et salah redeviens des
roches
ces roches donne du sable qui
redeviennent des roches les végétaux
pour ismaël il redonne des végétaux
vous avez ce qu'on appelle un cycle
c'est un cycle biologique donc alors
cette période sa vie avec des temps qui
sont facilement de l'ordre du million
d'années pour reconstituer un gisement
par exemple qui a été épuisé yp valoir 1
millions 10 millions cent millions
d'années
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu en dehors de
l'échelle humaine par contre l'homme lui
l'a16 qui est de l'ordre de la
génération ou même 25 30 ans alors on va
prendre exemple de l'aluminium d'un
gisement
on va le mettre dans le cycle humain il
va servir pendant 5 10 ans et puis on va
le jeter et pour redonner de l'aluminium
d'un gisement
il va mettre deux ou trois millions
d'années donc à ce moment-là il est
perdu pour nous et ce qu'il faut c'est
éviter cette coupure du cycle que
représente jeter les matériaux jetait
les produits utilisant ou ce gaspillage
se considéra pour vous donner qu'un
chiffre aux états unis chaque année on
gaspille sous forme d'aliments jetés
dans les ordures des aliments jetés dans
les ordures on en est exactement de quoi
doubler le rallye de la ration
alimentaire de tous les indiens
c'est à dire de 700 millions la nuit
on a donné de mauvaises habitudes aux
gens depuis mettons au depuis 1900 1920
ou droit et l'art est un peu de la
grande crise puis ça redémarre et
surtout à partir de 47 48
on a habitué on a habitué les gens
dépensent et à consommer la consommation
d'eau venant à ce moment là un indice de
richesse
[Musique]
oh
dans le temps il était absolument
impensable de chuter quelque chose d'un
petit peu important on avait déjà du mal
à acheter des aliments achetés un
morceau de pomme c'est vrai le mythe du
temps qu'on devait conserver est un
mythe extrêmement importants dont moi
qui ai 50 ans je vous garantis que dans
marianne elle j'en ai souvent entendu
parler même cuisent amant pu réunir
maintenant on se contente pas acheter du
pain ou des brochettes des vêtements
j'ai même des membres
c'est très bien on change de monde tous
les jours
oui entendus la semaine prochaine mardi
10h excusez moi monsieur oui mardi 12
heures tout ce qui est consommation de
matière première production de matériaux
à partir de matières premières vierges
et facilité rô le des taxes ou même on
donne des primes ou des subventions pour
et au contraire on taxe tout ce qui est
recyclage
aussi bien le transport par exemple ça
coûte plus cher de transporter une tonne
d'ordures contenant nets ont 10% de fer
qu'il transportait un minerai contenant
10 % de verre il n'y a pas des
incitations possible pour essayer de se
renverser la vapeur
on peut en particulier faire
les usa par exemple ont décidé que tout
le papier qui serait que tout papier qui
seraient consommés par les
administrations seraient constituées à
au moins 50% par du papier recyclé pour
les constructions pour les constructions
d'immeubles dépendant aussi d
administration ca doit être
essentiellement des matériaux constitué
recyclé qui doivent être utilisés donc
il faut il faut agir comme ça il faut
par exemple taxer les bouteilles qui
sont non sinon qu'ils peuvent pas être
consignées comme on disait en comme on
disait il ya pas tellement longtemps des
mois et au contraire des taxes et celles
qui sont consignés c'est à dire donner
une espèce de prime à la casse zone et
héritera d'une et primes à l'espérance
de vie
plus aéré plus un matériau qui a demandé
de nombreuses heures de travail qui a
demandé donc un apport d'énergie humaine
dure longtemps
- il doit coûter cher par rapport à ceux
qui doivent être jetés alors on peut
vous répondre prenant pour exemple
automobile que si on consommait moins
d'automobiles ça risquerait d'avoir des
répercussions sur l'industrie
c'est un changement considérable du
système si c ur actuellement on est
habitué à garder des automobiles peu de
temps on change les couleurs photo même
pour oublier pendant longtemps
l'essentiel des transformations aux
etats-unis c'était de changer les
couleurs et bien donc maintenant il faut
dire aux gens vous allez au contraire
vous avez une vieille automobile vous la
gardez depuis longtemps et bien vous
êtes un meilleur conducteur quel crétin
qui lui a bousillé sa voiture en deux
ans et demi
[Musique]
parfaitement avoir de très bonnes
voitures qui coûteront plus cher au
point de vue fabrication qui compteront
plus cher au point de vue entretien dont
qui respecteront le circuit économique
classique il éteint et les théories
économiques classiques qui dureront plus
longtemps qui permettront d'économiser
les matériaux si par exemple les
français utilisaient une automobile tous
les dix ans au lieu de l'utiliser
mettons tous les deux ans et demi lisez
si on peut dire tous les deux ans et
demi comme ils le font actuellement ça
permettrait d'économiser en disant 40
millions de tonnes de métaux et de
produits diverses cpo totalement
ridicule tant de production inférieur à
4 billes d'acier de fer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire alors pour
inciter les particuliers et les
industriels a changé complètement de
mentalité ça sera sûrement très
difficile il faut à ce moment là tu
l'état soit bien persuadé d'ailleurs
l'intérêt du problème et se rendre
compte que cette politique d'économie
devrait lui permettre vraiment à mon
avis vraiment facilement comme on le
pense pour l'énergie on pense pour
l'énergie par exemple on peut économiser
en 2 3 125% du chauffage de 100% des
chauffages c'est tout de même économiser
près de 10% de l'énergie française
actuelle bon et ça on peut le faire sans
méthode coercitive du tout organe il
faut qu'on le fasse pour l'ensemble se
dire pour tous à quel ce ça représente
ça représente un peu d'eau qui vous
prouve en choses et beaucoup d'énergie
et beaucoup de matières premières qui
sont non à nous la piel valent beaucoup
c'est à dire quand on achète une
bouteille comme ça on achète emballages
on achète essentiellement l'emballage
est bien à ça ça il faut se dire non ça
c'est fini il faut donc qu'on ait une
politique basée sur l'économie d'énergie
qu'est-ce que recyclage des déchets ne
consomme pas beaucoup
ils consomment de l'énergie en
consomment relativement peu par rapport
à ce que coûte l'énergie pour sortir le
produit de base du minerai
enfin combien de temps pour que change
complètement le système économique si
vous avez une guerre il faut un an
si vous avez trop de guerre au moins il
faut 120 en trente ans je dépends des
crises dépend de la façon dont les gens
sont sensibilisés
je crois que pour l'instant de toute
façon l'accélération du temps et elle
est l'accélération des problèmes étaient
actuellement on sera amené à changer
relativement rapidement système
économique
en tout cas entre le monde que nous
avons actuellement il celui que nous
aurons d'ici 20 ou 25 ans aura des
différences absolument considérable
[Musique]